look at that huh your hair just frills
out like Japanese [ __ ] hair hey what is
going on YouTube I know I'm late with
this video I'm supposed to do it about a
week ago
well busy and I don't leave but I check
it out and what can I say the size oh my
god you know recently I've been trying
to do this thing where I'm a bit more
descent I'm trying to do that thing that
everybody said in LA you know all those
[ __ ] hipsters you know putting more
positive energy into the youtubes really
[ __ ] does that mean you [ __ ]
moonstone collecting [ __ ] I don't like
it I'm throwing that [ __ ] out the window
I'm going back to the way I used to be
just talking [ __ ] because man sometimes
somebody got to do it now if you don't
know about this [ __ ] but most likely you
have heard of it
let me update you real quick I'll poke a
restaurant out in Santa Monica just
opened up and there's a lady who freaked
the [ __ ] out because she's on another
couple being too affectionate we are
waiting for you to finish up so we're
chatting you're a heinous person now
this really would make news or it would
have bothered me so much but the way the
[ __ ] [ __ ] reacted was uncalled for
I'm Tahoe can you just finish up your
transaction we'll order and we can just
move on oh my god
I would just like to order and then hey
and according to the couple it was just
a kiss on the forehead and a little bit
of flirting so it really wasn't that bad
but because the [ __ ] decided to get
online you already know what it is LG I
said he let's get it let's go goose need
some dick I have never seen somebody so
[ __ ] annoying with that much dick at
me in my life I said it [ __ ] you got
pick at thee I'm saying it sounds like
you're mad and the reason why you're
attacking them is because you ain't got
a good man to hold you down and show you
affection your [ __ ] [ __ ] gargling
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on in your
life that's so [ __ ] terrible that
when another couple shows a little bit
of public display of affection it
bothers you that much I'm sure what I
thought she was sucking a dick at the
middle of a restaurant it was a kiss on
the forehead oh my god you see at this
point right here is where you knew you
[ __ ] up so we'll see who's loser as in
his letter you're [ __ ] your
girlfriend in a public restaurant acting
like a prostitute when you go from zero
to 100 in an argument or when you're
trying to prove a point it just goes to
show that either you lost the argument
or you have nothing logical to say so
you just outline attack the [ __ ] it's
kind of like you're me I'm a [ __ ] your
puppies that don't even add up I go oh
ma yo business why the [ __ ] is in your
business to go ahead and police somebody
on how and when they should be
affectionate to somebody else that none
of your [ __ ] business and if it
bothered you you could have just picked
up your [ __ ] food walked out and then
move the big [ __ ] out of there
[Music]
no need for water here than you me why
you gotta go there why don't you go back
to your spacious you alien-looking [ __ ]
lookin like a Puritan mistress like you
turn butter heavy weekend you big [ __ ]
it's like the cheapest trumpet insult oh
god it's so [ __ ] overuse I keep
telling this to people if you're going
to be [ __ ] racist be creative with
that [ __ ] at least know about the
culture that you're making fun of go
back to your country if you still have
not figured out does it make sense
because you came here from somewhere
else I just don't understand how [ __ ]
dumb people can be that you can't even
use an insult correctly people as an
Asian person you could have been
multiple things you could have tell them
to go [ __ ] himself at his dick hole with
a pair of chopsticks I'm going to give
you some life advice why don't you focus
on some other issues for example let's
focus on the fact that you look like
Ronda Rousey after a deep depression
let's focus on the fact that you look
like you've kidnapped cats and [ __ ] them
on your spare time I can't believe you
actually said that they were having sex
they were not [ __ ] in front of you
because if they were you should have
called me up so I could have watched
let's just say they were being
excessively affectionate the scene that
you caused didn't help the situation and
it just made you look like a fat [ __ ]
so not only did you ruin everybody
else's experience you made yourself look
like a dumbass and on top of that now
the whole world thinks your [ __ ] smells
and by the way you are very lucky then
these people were very well composed
you said [ __ ] that were fighting words
if you call somebody a ho you call
somebody a [ __ ] that means that maybe
you might have to get stabbed and I'm
almost a hundred percent sure that if
you guys said pork chops and skills will
come out the moral of the story is
people must yo [ __ ] business if it
don't hurt you don't hurt nobody else
stop
see your way through because honestly
it's not going to do [ __ ] go home open
up some pornhub just eat a sandwich and
fall asleep it always helps me out the
girlfriend why the way Masbate sandwich
hey what is going on youtube I hope you
like that video you guys already know
one was a little late with that and I
wanted to do it earlier but I couldn't
because I didn't see the video so I'm
sorry but I got more videos coming along
the way I got more things to do I'm
super super busy like I said I'm sorry
but come on I did like two videos last
week and I'm doing a one this Sunday and
I did like two videos again this week so
that's pretty [ __ ] good told you I
never leaving you and by the way secret
stuff coming up real soon
Love Me Tender mmm